Hey, what's going on is bill burns
time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and Ah,
just checking in on you,
seeing how you winks go and
as you slogging your way
through your cubicle life,
something you never wanted, you know,
but who you going to blame? Huh?
You gonna blame society like all
of these people on social networks.
Is it ever their fault? Um, anyways,
I have a special guest as promised on
the Monday morning podcast. I said,
God dammit. And I delivered.
We have the amazing,
the unbelievably talented
and hilarious Bill Hader,
star of the new incredible show on Hbo.
Barry starring Henry Winkler. Stephen
wrote, I was my cheat sheet. Where's,
who's the one place you girlfriend?
She crushes it. Sarah gold. Oh my God.
She's amazing. Yeah, she's, she's
amazing. She's amazing. And uh,
it's eight incredible episodes.
Thank you.
I saw the first two and then
my link expired and then
I couldn't get it to play.
I got a new link and then I
melted down and my wife said,
you're bringing tension into the house.
So that was,
that's been my experience so far. But
having said that, I absolutely loved,
loved the first two that I saw.
And there's another ad.
The other actor, they with the alopecia
there. Anthony? Yeah, Anthony Carrigan.
Oh my God. No, Hank [inaudible].
Great Name. Incredible actors. So, um,
I was actually tested,
give people background.
I was going to interview all of you
guys at the now defunct nerd melt.
Yeah. That's gone because of
that incident I believe. Yeah.
Because what happened to
me, hey, yes. So you, you,
you were supposed to come down
there with Henry, Steven and uh,
the other guys and uh,
you have a peanut allergy.
So not allergy in the game they
gave me, well, here's the thing,
it's my own. I, I blame
myself so I can have almonds.
I'm okay with almonds or other nuts on
bandwidth. So like, oh, coffee and go, Oh,
can I have almond milk in it? And again,
like a racist, but with just like nuts,
just nuts. Those are the,
you stay with your own.
You stay with the almonds. All these
other ones. Get them out of my house.
All right, here, you're a peanut
supremacy. I've never heard of that.
I thought if you had like a peanut
allergy, I found that out on a movie.
I had something, a whoa that has almonds
in it and I had it and I go, I'm fine.
And then I went home and I had an Epi pen
and sat there with almonds and ate it.
And what is an Epi pen?
That's what you take in case you haven't,
you're doing a stabbing motion in
your way. Do a stabbing motion into,
you're like, yeah, I stat
you stab yourself with the
epipen. So it takes what?
Like your blood pressure that like,
no,
it just shoots you full of adrenaline
basically. And then you just,
you're able to breathe. It gets a big
shot of so, so when you drank this,
so you were supposed to come in and all
of a sudden somebody basically gave the
equivalent to, you have a couple of these
boys and they gave me will almond milk,
but it was this fancy coffee
place and they were like, well,
we have an almond cashew blend that
comes in. I can't have cashews.
Oh. So I had that and I took
a drink of it backstage,
excited about to go on and I went,
I got to go. When you drink that,
how quick do you know this is like
getting bit by a Cobra? Yeah, yeah.
Like you just know that wasn't good.
I need the answer. You don't get,
you don't get bit by a Cobra and go, I'm
going to wait. We can do this 20 minutes.
I could do the podcast,
I'm fine.
My legs all black and blue and I can't
really feel my feet anymore. And Yeah,
you bet. I'm fine. It was just one
fan. Yeah, I'm fine. And my dad was,
the biggest bomber is my
dad is a giant fan of yours.
And my dad was really excited too.
And he flew in because we had the premiere
and so he wanted to see it and I go,
I gotta go. And he was like, what? Oh No.
And he's like, fine. He goes, you're fine.
Shake it off. I go, no, no,
no. And he's like, you're
fine, you're fine. I go, what?
I want to see bill brewer. And I'm
like, well, I gotta go, I gotta go.
You can stay here, go. And he's
like, oh, I'll go, you know,
let's get you some Benadryl
and all that stuff. Okay. So,
so what happens is you with your
throat closes up. Yeah. And so guy,
someone ran out and got me Benadryl and
that, that was fine. And then I got home.
Did. But how bad is like, how much are you
laboring breathing? I'm breathing fine.
It's just, I said I, I,
it was in my mouth for only a couple
of seconds and then I spit it out.
But it was enough to make everything
start to kind of look like hives inside
your mouth and your throat. Oh my God.
Oh yeah, that's, yeah, it was awful.
So then when you take the Benadryl,
how long does it fills that
out and then you get groggy.
And then I did the Epi pen,
which then makes you all jacked up.
And then I went and did the
premiere and yeah. Sucked. Oh,
so you able to work then that night? Yeah,
I had to, yeah. It was like HBO was like,
we need you yet.
So do you travel when you travel?
Do you have those things with you
have my backpack out right there.
Yeah.
And that's the whole reason I buy one of
those. Yeah, you can go. Yeah. You get a
prescription for it.
Yeah.
Cause I didn't do that for
like the writer's room on
efforts to family. You know,
when you just get like burned out,
like I can't think of any more funny.
Should Epi pen just stab yourself.
Yeah, let's just do that. Be Pins. Yeah.
Well No, it's like this dumb thing though.
When you do it, everyone thinks it's,
but it's, it's, it's just more,
the motion of it looks more
severe than it actually is.
It's just like a little pin prick,
but it's like buried into this.
You go through your pants.
No,
you gotta pull your pants down and go
right on your leg. And then, but uh,
so you stab it and then you push the push
the thing down at the same time. Yeah.
You can't tell me you don't feel a little
bit like John Rambo when you do. Yeah,
no, you totally do. Yeah.
You station yourself up.
That's awesome. But I'm such a
wimp that, um, you know, well,
I want you to know you not being there
really threw me off my game because I've,
I've never hosted one of those before.
So it was an honor that I got to do it.
And one of my goals was like,
I was just like,
I am not asking Henry Winkler about
playing Arthur funds early. I am,
I am going to, I'm going to do anything.
I'm gonna talk about night shift.
I left you and
nothing, which, and then by
the end, I was just like,
they were helping me through the
interview and then somehow I just said,
I go, you know, I'm running out of stuff,
but my goal is I'm not bringing up,
you know, who, and then he just broke into
the character. Just say like, you know,
that character maybe a lot of money
and put my kids through college.
I can't do the fonts. And then I was all
excited. Like, oh my God, he did the fun.
When he does it
you, it's like, it's like, uh,
you know Mickey Mouse showing I am John
Malaney said it's like Mickey mouse
showing up or something. It's like
a thing I grew up, I'm like, oh,
that's television.
Is that terrible and heal.
He said it to Alec Berg and I
wants an Alec cocreative Barry,
he's not a very effusive guy.
And he was standing behind
me and Henry told this story,
we're going to be non emotional. Yeah.
He's, he's, he's Swedish, Swedish,
Swedish, you know, cause like,
Huh. Yeah, I've done stand up.
I've done stand up through the hole.
Uh,
that whole region up there
was the funniest one. Well
I would just sitting there,
they were trying to solve
the problem of the day.
Like I would sit there and I'm doing
the joke and it was just quiet and quiet
and quiet. And then if
somebody is just fine, goes,
why didn't you just blah blah blah.
And I was just like,
is that what you fucking guys are doing?
I go, you don't need to solve these.
This isn't like a self help thing.
It's just she'll just kick your
wife out of the house. Yes.
Battery out in the backyard and say
she went to a mothers to do that yet.
So that was Finland. Oh Bye. If
we noticed there was a huge
difference was that the Baltic Sea,
like Norway and Sweden as a certain level
of emotionally disconnected and then
when you go to the over there where this
spooning with Russia and they actually
defeated Russia and had to give up part
of their land because they paired up
with Hitler, you know, they had,
they wouldn't between the two
craziest people in the last century.
It's like who we went to, the crazier
one. Which and who lost. Yeah.
Don't ever go there. I don't know if
he, they went to the crazy one. They,
they were equals they would
peers. Yeah. They were like,
if there was a way that they both
could have won the war and lived, yeah.
I guess the other guy lived right style
live. I don't know shit about history.
Like they could sit back like, you
know, old NBA players. Yeah, exactly.
Like when wilt and Bill
Russell get together,
they could be talking about murdering
people and their knees are bad.
They can't really walk around much.
They're exaggerating their stats,
but no, they, yeah, it was this,
yeah, no, Alec is a, he's hilarious.
I mean he wrote on Seinfeld and curb your
enthusiasm. He's, he's a very funny guy,
but he's not, he's very
kind of quiet and, and uh,
Henry did the Fonz, he just
told a story and I said, Oh,
I had to tell all these people, you know,
because Henry and life is very kind of,
hello, how are you? Oh,
that's what makes it when you
meet him or you seem just taught.
And that's what makes it even more
incredible. That guy came out of this guy.
Yeah. He's like, I was on the phone in
my car, hands free. And I'm like, okay,
be safe, being safe. And then, you know,
and then it'd be like, Oh, you know,
the Fonz would say a part like the Red
Sea, you know, he would do something.
And Alec was behind me and he went,
oh my God. You know, it was the most,
he just went, I can't,
I can't believe why he,
it was the most effusive I've ever
seen. And like he just went, oh,
I can't believe that it gave us chills,
you know? Well, because it it like,
like you said, when you talk to the
guy, it's nowhere. It's like Mel Blanc.
When Mel Blanc with different
voices like you, you'd be like this,
there's no way this guy does bugs
bunny or does you send to me Sam?
I couldn't hear him and any of it.
And I feel like with him,
when he's just talking you,
it's just like,
this can't be the guy that played that
guy in. All of a sudden he does the voice.
This is hilarious.
Now I'm going to sit here and
talking about and being the fonts.
This whole flipping the interview.
Sorry,
I left you with nothing though because I
left and then you were stuck with that.
It sounds to me like you blew off the
interview and I'm not buying this whole
fucking stabbing yourself.
Then somehow you made it was a premiere.
There was no,
there was no fucking nerd melt to
talk about some jackasses podcast.
I get it though. Super bottles
that an HBO Premiere for Barry.
No, it was all like gastric does
checks. They weren't done over,
they were working there. No, no,
but I, they, they had me. Um,
no,
I,
that was a thing where it was one of the
things that you leave and then HBO is
going, Oh my God. Oh my God.
Well, you know, the thing
is, it's his show. You gotta,
you know gotta be, well, what do we
got? Can we send a doctor over there?
Can we do anything?
What can we do?
And they going old school centered
hookers in April. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like,
this is Dr feelgood and yeah,
it's my badge briefcase. All right.
You're going to be up in notes
done buddy. Well, everybody I know that
has been watching it. It's just been like,
you know what I love about it and what
I wanted to talk to you about is I love
when somebody that's known for doing
comedy gets to do some drama stuff because
for some reason they think that a,
I don't know who the comedian was
that screwed it up for the rest of us.
I want to know who that person was and
also who the person was that fucked up so
bad that we all actors now have to get
there like nine hours before you're gonna
get
called. You just sit there with a
fake mustache glued on your face.
It's just like,
who fucked up?
Who fucked up fatty Arbuckle?
Who was the fire fatty Arbuckle
just was always 20 minutes.
You had 30 hours late, 30 hours late.
So now they got to bring you in.
Got to get the Arbuckle rule. I want
all these assholes here now at my worst,
my worst, whenever I got you, I got
called. I was went to a
set at four o'clock in the
afternoon and I didn't work.
Didn't utter a word until
one in the morning. Oh,
I've done that where I got called on a,
I remember a tropic thunder.
There was this huge a party scene and
it was just one of those things where I
just learned that it's all communication
where Ben Stiller's directing and Ben
and Ben, I think he kept saying,
rob, my character's name is rob,
but there's also an actor named rob.
And he was like, rob should be in there.
Right. You know, and the first
aid went, oh, Bill's not,
Bill's not working the day. So they
would wake me up, oh, call me flooded.
The Columbian,
I would go in at two in the morning,
is that one wherever shooting
like Hawaii or something, go in,
put me in makeup.
And I would just sit in my trailer and
then finally I get hired, you know,
kind of like, what am I doing? You
know, and I'm not in the scene.
And I would go to set and Ben would
go, well, the fuck are you doing here?
And then two days later, hey, we need you
to come in, what's going on? And like,
well, what are you doing here? And
he goes, no, Rob, rob the actor, rob,
not the fucking, you know,
and I showed up twice.
Oh, it was terrible. Waiting in those
trailers actually understood my dog more.
Yeah. I was just thinking, why is
this thing fucking sleep all the time?
And it's basically,
if you have nothing to do,
it goes back to sir survival where it's
like we're gonna shut down your body and
just store up this energy.
So like the level of tired you get.
But how does my dog, no, every
episode of the Tyra banks show,
cause that's seems to be
the only thing on television
or do you go to the trailers?
I've never had the TV work. Oh,
they got a flat screen TV inhibit.
It never works.
It's just some like whatever signal you
just hear the other actor next to you
clearing this road every
couple of hours. Yeah. Yeah.
On the phone with their agent.
I'm not going to do that.
They want me to do this. I'm
not going to do it. Well, let's,
let's promote it a little bit here because
uh, uh, as far as like, it's on Hbo.
Okay. The final episode is this
Sunday? Yeah, there's eight of them.
And if people want to go
back and watch all of them,
I imagine in 2018 HBO has
a way to create an HBO go.
You have that, you can go check it
out. And I think, uh, Amazon, Hulu,
those places, well I'm old school
in that. I like to watch an episode.
I liked the old way where you watched it
and then you had to wait a week for it
to come out. And then, and then another
one went and, and like, like, um,
I don't know all the shows that I watch,
you try to guess what was going to happen.
And now like there's all these
great shows that just dump it on.
People just sit down and it's like,
it's like the greatest bottle of
wine every night. Shotgun it. Wow.
It was amazing. And then like what
else can I have now? And it just,
and I also have, I feel for like the
amount of work that was put into this,
cause that's what happens with the fucking
cartoon I'm doing. Which just this,
I actually did a cartoon after because
of those getting called at four in the
afternoon. Not Work until one. I'm
like, dude, fuck this live action shit.
I'm going to do a car too.
Well,
I just show up in a baseball
hat and sweatpants and I
didn't realize that it was
like 90 times slower and then the thing
comes out and people will watch it all
in one night. That's great. When's the
next season coming out? He's just like,
he can't, well, might as well
just be a movie. You know
what I mean? It's like, Oh,
put it in the theater. I
Dunno, but I, I like it.
But you do this and for eight
weeks people are talking about,
there's like a level of the
high intensity level of go, go,
go. I have no idea where this is
going to go. Yeah. And that's,
it's fun having people come up to me,
you know,
at my kid's school or whatever going,
hey, so this is what's going to happen,
right? Yeah. So I'm still going to kill
you. Yeah. One guy came up and he's like,
Stephen Root. He's a figment of his
imagination. Right. It's not real.
Yeah. You might be Ryan, you know, I
got you figured out, asshole. I'm like,
all right. Yeah. I used to watch lost. I
know where you're going with this. Yeah.
The, it's all figments of a,
some else's imagination, right?
It's all a figment to get eight seasons
or whatever the hell it is. But then,
you know,
something I actually,
something I want to bring up before
I forget is that, you know, uh,
that you're from Tulsa,
Oklahoma,
and I was telling you earlier that that
is one of my favorite cities to perform
standup.
And they got the Brady theater there,
which evidently some ridiculous race
riot happened. Really? I guess so.
I mean, I walked in, there was a white
guy, I'm like, Oh, this has a nice vibe.
This feels like really great.
And this, why is this so
comfortable? Yeah. And it's,
um, it's, and then they've got
all this great cause all these,
all these people who'd never been there.
When I told him I'm in Tulsa, Oklahoma,
and everyone's like, oh
Jesus Christ, you know,
what are you gonna fucking go ride a
bull out there? Like go cow tipping.
And they don't understand
like how like the,
the food there is incredible massive
amounts of hipsters at see exact opposite
thing that you would a picture.
But that old theater there and I said,
George Carlin, they're ones, I remember
there was a first comedy show ever.
So what year did you see him?
I don't remember. I was young.
I remember my dad. It was a thing where
I got to get snuck into the thing,
but my dad, God, I don't remember how to
be in the 80s. I saw him in the 80s too.
Yeah.
And I started seeing him and just my
face hurting from laughing and just it,
and not knowing that he did like
two hours or I don't know why I was,
it was just super long. But
to me I was like, oh, keep
going, keep going, you know,
and uh, and just leaving on this high
and just going, wow, that was good.
That have an effect that
you like at that point,
did you already know you wanted to
get into comedy or, no, I mean I,
to me that just seemed like a,
I mean I was someone, I didn't,
I and I still have,
you have very anxious and having to
get up in front of people. And so I,
I the idea of going up there alone and
telling jokes and how quick he was,
but I loved watching stand up my dad's
giant fan of Stan to stand up and so,
and in the 80s and that, you
know, every TV, you know,
you had the a and e the
evening at the Improv, MTV,
half hour comedy hour, those a
hundred watches. I saw those. I mean,
I would run into like
Jeff Garlin and be like,
do you remember he used to do that,
I think Adam West,
Adam West and going to be what Bagel
and he gets hit with a, you, you,
you have our comedy on TV. Yeah.
And he went, what? How did you know?
And then when I met Judd Apatow for the
first time, I go used to do a bit about,
uh, uh, you know, your nose, uh, you know,
being stuffed up and how it
switches, you know, w w you know,
you get congested in one nostril
and goes in a stolen. Yeah,
though I remember that. Yeah. But, uh,
yeah, I can freak people out. I remember,
I forget the name of the comedian,
but he had this great bit he was
talking about, I ran into the guy,
I don't even remember his name,
but I was one of my favorite bits that
I saw from one of those evening at the
Improv.
And he was talking about how he was the
youngest kid in this big family and how
strict the parents were with the older
kids. And by the time it got down to him,
it was, uh, you know, uh, it
was basically the only rule was
no heroin in the living room. And then
one of my favorite tags of all time,
it was just like, Brian, you're
not using one of the good spoons.
And that was just like,
you know,
for a clean joke and all I really love
and I got to actually run into him and
tell him.
And I remember just talking to that
guy and him just looking at me like,
how the fuck does this kid, oh my God,
Bob Nelson, that guy, there's a guy,
Bob Nelson, I'm a dual
crazy. And then the,
I saw him open for Rodney Dangerfield
right after back this back to school.
Came out dude, that summer and
great woods. Yeah, in Mansfield,
Massachusetts.
I saw Rodney Dangerfield.
And then a few weeks later I saw Eddie
Murphy on the raw Toro and the weather
girls weathered girls opened up.
They sing,
it's raining men and they were big girls.
And I remember he came out and was doing
all these jokes about I got to check
out the stage cause the weather girls
can fuck up the stage back when you could
fat shame people.
And um,
he had like the purple suit
on and all of that stuff.
He always close with his daddy, didn't
tinker toys and the, the, the, the,
the toy thing. Remember that the, I don't
remember what he closed. I mean, Eddie,
Eddie, we would eat our tinker toys. Any
of that whole thing that he would do is,
because that was a thing seen raw, which
now you watch raw and you're like, Geez,
there's some stuff you can do now.
And then. So, yeah. But that, uh,
that the end bear to him, I know, I
know, but it's just lazy as 30 years ago.
But you go like, uh, yeah, at SNL
you would watch something, oh,
you guys gotta watch raw and
then they would come back and go,
why did you find that funny?
It was so offensive and
everything and go, wow, yeah.
Oh Man. You know, uh, what about
the thing at the end? You know,
I would just try to concentrate on the
thing I found. Oh No. When I watched that,
it makes me sad that he stopped
because he was 25 years old.
And, uh, when he was
talking about, uh, you know,
the level of success he got to and
thinking about getting married and seen
Johnny Carson getting divorced and all
of that stuff and saying, well, you know,
women get half, that's bullshit.
No, somebody, when we get
half and the woman goes,
that's right. He goes, Nah,
that's bullshit. And was like,
he was going to that next level where
it's like, oh no, this guy is gonna,
you know, start saying what he thinks
about all this stuff. Cause you know,
the delirious was amazing.
Yeah. But it was uh, you know,
Ralph Kramden having sex with,
you know,
yeah, yeah. That's so goo and all
stuff. And then all of a sudden
he was like, you seen this
guy finding his voice and uh,
and then, I mean, who knew that I would
go see him and that that was actually
you like the farewell tour?
Yeah,
well I think when he did the thing
at the end of raw was a thing I saw,
you know, as he, when I
was young and it went, wow,
he's just by himself and he might as
well buy and be by himself in his room.
You know what I mean?
It was like he went into this other place,
you know, it wasn't like
jokes, you know what I mean?
It was like [inaudible] he's just talking
and he just went to this place and
it's the thing I, I'm never as funny. I,
the funniest I'll ever be is in the lunch
room with my friends and they were all
funnier than me,
you know what I mean?
Everybody was high school with his
funny than I was way funnier than me.
And I still see those guys and they'll
just like, they'll send me a text about,
one of my friends hated three billboards.
That movie in his text made me laugh
harder than anything that I've read.
Any comedian. I know. All I do is hang
around with comedy people and I'll,
and I'm like, what? You know, he
works at a window store in Oklahoma,
some plebes so funny.
Well, just how they live their
life. I got a buddy of mine, uh,
Joe de Rosa was open and for me and
you know, it was after the show,
he didn't Boston, I got all my boss at
Fred's, you know, hanging out or whatever.
And uh,
one of my buddies offered to buy around
the drinks are all ordering drinks and
my buddy Joe ordered a white Russian
and my friend was just done with them
and he came up and he goes, dude, what's
up with your boy? I go, what's the matter?
He goes, he just sorted a white Russian
and I didn't really think about it.
I was like, I only drink white
Russians. He likes, you know, whatever.
That movie with the Dude, he likes
big old ass guy. He's a big Lebowski.
I didn't think anything about it.
And then the end of the night I'm walking
back with Joe and he's just like, hey,
you know, like hanging out
with friends. He goes, yeah,
that's cool. He's like, dude,
what are you friends?
Was,
he was like really friendly
and he was like talking to me.
Then all of a sudden out of nowhere,
he just stopped talking to me like it was,
it was all based on the fact that he
ordered a white Russian and we were well
into our thirties late thirties
and this guy still to this day,
I remember a long time, I
don't trust that guy. I don't,
I don't know anybody like that.
I remember a long time ago,
he for some reason was giving the
responsibility to watch the house of this
married couple and of course,
so he immediately has this all over there
and we're getting hammered and um,
and he's taking care of the house.
He went down into the basement and there
was some sort of a faucet nozzle is
something you had to turn on or off.
And The lady left the
post it note on it saying,
you might have to turn it a little hard
on. My husband said it's a little fussy.
And my buddy just went out
and just immediately turned
it with no problem at all.
And he just, it gets
mudders, this guy's a post,
we're in his house and he probably, he
just said that to his wife, just being,
you know,
gentlemanly to a woman.
And then this my friend just
totally judge this guy that he was,
he was not a man like his man.
Like that's what I love
about my friends back there.
How easily you could lose your
man card and you have no idea.
And they won't even tell you why
they just stopped talking to you. Oh,
it's the worst.
When my friends,
they visited the set
of Barry and you know,
I'm doing all these things or whatever
and I have been assistant. Uh Huh. Oh,
okay. It's over. She
walked over, here's your,
here's your coffee. Well man, you
can't get your own coffees now. What?
What do you see machines? The
machines right there, dude,
just go over and get your own goddamn
coffee bill. And I'm like, well,
I'm focusing on, I don't give a shit.
You Go, why are you making her get your,
and I'm like, no, not,
you're right, you're right.
I shouldn't be machines right there. I
don't know. You're not in, you're right.
You know what I mean? I just feel
like an asshole. And then I'm like,
why did I invite you here to, you
know, uh, make me feel bad and then,
hey man, did you try the dessert? I,
and I'm trying not to eat anything bad
because you know the guys in the military
and you're like, oh fuck you
man. Now you're dining now.
And I'm like, why? I yeah.
They just keep you real.
[inaudible] I ended up, I just go back
harder at them. I can't say, you know?
Yeah. We're really trying
to work on my man tits.
Like you have miss the only way to keep
them off. You do that. Another friend,
the exact same party he was telling me,
he was telling this story.
He's going,
where are you staying?
I told him the hotel I was staying at p
and he was a construction guy. Goes, oh,
I worked on that. He goes,
crazy story. We will,
we will put in a flagpole or something
up and he goes, stuff the fucking cable,
Bro. This guy was underneath
directing the cable broken,
just came slamming down on this guy.
Oh Geez. I go, Jesus Christ. I go,
did he die? And he goes, did he
die? He was in fucking pieces.
And I go, well, what happened?
He goes, oh, guys were puking.
Some people jumped in that truck and drove
away and they got, his dad was there,
he had a heart attack. So we're all
just sitting there like dead silence.
And then he just out of know where
he goes, Eh, kid was kind of a dose.
And then he goes, he goes,
his dad was a good shit.
And that actually broke the tension in.
Everybody started laughing.
And I just remember thinking like,
you couldn't teach somebody
no in an acting class,
how to take to somebody to such
a dark place. And he sensed it.
He sensed that a laugh needed. The
comedy knew exactly where to go. Yeah.
Intuition as my friend.
Uh, I used to be a PA.
I was a production assistant for a long
time. And then I worked on this movie,
James Dean in an invented life there.
James Franco played James Dean
and this Guy Jason Lt Airy,
who's now a big first d now,
but he was a PA.
And again, what we're
talking about, he had a,
he had a real like Rambo knife,
like he got it from the props truck and
he's just taking chunks out of this tree
with it.
And he's just hitting this tree with
this giant knife and we're all kind of
sitting there whining. He's just
bullshitting with us. Was like,
look at this fucking thing. Wow.
Look at them like, look, it's really,
it's like an ax, you know, standing out.
And this other guy,
Bill Hardy,
this big guy walking over and you
use another PA smoking's here.
You guys are good. And Jason, he's weird.
This [inaudible] he pretends like he's
going to stab him. He just goes, hey, hey,
hey, don't fuck it. That's not
funny. Don't do that. Don't
do that. That's not cool.
Don't do that. [inaudible].
So bill walks away,
the props guy comes over and goes,
I have that same knife but the exact
same night, but it's retractable,
it's plastic, it's fake, you
know, and he goes, get it.
He takes it and he is the best
piece of acting I've ever seen.
Just totally calm pretending to like,
you know, cut up the tree, do everything,
just waiting for bill to come back.
Bill walks back, hey, how's it going?
Hey how you doing?
And he does the does the thing and,
and it just rears back
and stabs him in the
Oh God.
And Bill Goes,
oh no,
he is screening his reaction with water.
Like you just murdered
my just, he legitimately was
like, my friend just murdered
down laughing and we felt bad. And I've
told that story to other people and go,
that's horrible. That's not nice at all.
And I go, I know, but if you were there,
it was the funniest thing
I think I'd ever seen.
And because you're literally got
to see what was your friend do,
what would he do if he died? He would say,
why if he got murdered. But then Jason,
to your point, the reason I thought of
it was that he was such a good actor.
He was just like,
you couldn't have taught like anybody
else I think you would get and they would
want to run over to him and go,
hey, look in the night. And then,
you know what I mean?
When I would,
I would take the knife and walked up to
him and done it, but he had the patient,
the patients to keep like, no,
no, I have to keep this, this,
this lie up where he was pretending to
do that and we sat there waiting for him
for like 15 minutes and then he
kind of would meander back like, no,
we can't call him over.
We can't do this.
I want to be able to keep a
straight face. I'm the worst. Hey,
when you watch somebody do
something like that as an actor,
do you get something out of that?
Watching that guy like that? Yeah. Yeah.
You kind of go,
Oh wow,
that patients are so much of it too is
just kind of impersonating people are,
you know,
or doing nothing.
That was the thing he did that was
good was he didn't do anything.
Do you know what I mean?
He just was doing what he did before
and he kind of instinctively knew like,
well, that's how, that's
the best way to do this.
That's the best way to set the trap
is to make it look like nothing.
Nothing happened. Instead of, I would
have gone over there, I've been,
hey bill, come back or whatever. Are
those some of your favorite actors?
Are you a character actor guy as far
as like the guys that you watch because
you're acting on the series is, is
phenomenal. I kept, I kept calling, uh,
uh, my wife and go look at this is
like the best. It's, I'm telling you,
it's like the best work I've seen and
I love all this stuff that you've done,
but like this to actually,
I love it when they give a
funny guy a to show that, hey,
I can do these other things
too. Oh, thanks. Yeah.
So I was just curious now that I see
that you have that in the toolbox,
like who are some of your favorite actors?
Um, well, I mean it's not, I mean the,
I had a tape that, this is
kind of everybody, but, uh,
I had a VHS tape that had taxi driver
and raging bull on it and I would just
watch those a bunch and just watch Robert
De Niro on those movies. He does does,
it's kind of what we were talking about.
He doesn't do much, but he did enough,
you know, like he just, the way
my, it was behavior, but to,
to be honest, like I
like, uh, you know, uh,
um,
I like a lot of actors,
but I was always more excited by the
story. I, we watch a movie for a story,
but to me it's just more, it's more about
observing behavior of people. You know,
you watch like a documentary or I would
watch a guy like Jason Lt Arie do that
thing or whatever,
but it was the actors who could modulate
behavior instead of pushing and making
it like a performance. Right.
There's a movie called CAS.
It's this British movie from the late
sixties and then this is non-actor,
this kid in it who's phenomenal and
it just is because it's all just very
genuine. Right. You know what I mean?
Oh, okay. It's time for a little bit
of advertising. Oh, look who's back it.
Sold Zip red fruit up.
Talk about the challenges of finding great
talent and how the way you went about
it just did not work. Oh,
was inefficient. You know,
I tried to dig down deep into myself to
try to be a good comedian and it turned
out all I had was a bunch of Shit and
Dick Jokes down there and it was really
tough. And then I use ZipRecruiter
and all of a sudden, you know,
I started talking about Pussy Toe am I,
my comedy went to,
I don't fucking hire people, but I know
this app, this, this, is this an APP,
this product, this service. Let's
go with that. I know it works.
Ziprecruiter knew there was a smarter way,
so they built a platform that finds
the right job candidates for you.
These invitations have revolutionized
how you find your next hire.
In fact,
80% of employers who post
a job on ZipRecruiter get
a quality candidate through
the site and just one day and zip.
Okay?
Uh,
it doesn't stop there.
They even spotlight the strongest
applications you received,
so you never miss a great match. The
right candidates around there, a zip
recruiting is how you find them.
Businesses of all sizes
trusts ZipRecruiter for their
hiring needs. Right now,
my listeners can try Zack Hapara kroner.
That's right.
They can use it for free.
You can try it for free.
Just go to ziprecruiter.com/birth
and ziprecruiter.com/pat
one more time. Hi. Zip,
right.
The smartest way to hire.
Yeah.
[inaudible] be on days.
I'm sitting in my fucking car.
Gudu [inaudible] me,
I'm driving out to a bar.
I'm going to get hammered at the bar.
Take your piss in my soft underway on
my balls or feel great and on diesel.
Dry it up.
You don't need no more adult diapers.
Me undies are made with the sustainably
source material from beechwood trees
made out of trees. Man,
they're naturally soft.
Fiber makes a fabric that won't
sag down or write up. Trust me.
Once you got a pair on,
you'll get it,
and if you're already part
of the me undies family,
tell your friends about it through
their referral program though.
It's like Amway,
but with fucking panties,
they get a discount and you'll get
a store credit. It's a win win.
Miyagi's is sure you'll love their first
pair is so sure you'll love their first
pair of that.
If you're not happy,
they'll do whatever they can to get you
the right pair and if they can't keep
them and they'll refund you
so it's really risk free.
Free to try the best underwear ever.
Still not sure if,
wow me undies has a deal for my listeners,
first time purchasers get 20% off
their first pair of me undies and free
shipping.
Get your ass over to me on [inaudible]
dot com and treat yourself to get 20% off
your first pair and free shipping
and 100% satisfaction guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash
[inaudible] that's me on east.com/birthed.
Unbelievable.
How hot your car gets.
The second you shut it off and keep
the windows and doors shut. Oh,
look who's here,
Huh?
D
when you shop online,
do you suddenly turn into a tab?
Horner loading dozens and dozens of new
tabs on your browser and search of a
Promo Code,
just one that works.
Afraid to close any of them and fear of
missing out on a deal before you crash
your browser yet again. Try. Hi. Hey.
Yeah,
honey, it's the free browser. Add on.
That's overnight that over 9 million
people are using every day to save money
while they shop online in two clicks.
Add honey to any browser for free
than shop like you normally do.
Honey Scans and tests,
millions of coupons in the
background and checkout.
Heidi automatically applies the best
coupon. Honey never means honey.
It never does.
Time magazine calls honey.
Basically ev basically free money.
Over 9 million people have used oh Harney
every day and together they've saved
millions of dollars. There's no reason
not to add honey to your browser today.
I'm running out of ways to say it.
It's free.
Just takes two clicks to install
and will save you tons of money.
Get honey for free@joinhoney.com
slash bird that's two words.
Join.
Hi Dee.
mmm.com/bird start
saving with honey today.
That's join honey.com/burr and write this
people next door working on the house.
They think I'm fucking crazy. All
right, he looks everybody Helux.
There's nobody on the planet like you,
so why would you buy a fucking
mattress built for everyone else? Next,
please mention all the talking points
below. What I'm gonna you wrote it.
I'm going to read it.
Uh,
working with the world's leading sleep
experts heloc sleep developed a mattress
accustomize as customized to
your specific height, weight,
and sleep preferences so you can get
the best goddamn sleepy life at an
unbelievable price. Here's how
it works. Go to helic sleep.com.
Fill out their two minutes sleep quiz,
and they'll design your custom mattress.
They can even customize each
side for you and your partner.
In 2018 he looks sleep has
taken customized sleep to
the next level with the
helix pillow.
The all new pillows are fully adjustable
so you can achieve perfect comfort
regardless of sleep position of body type.
Do you want to kill your wife?
They got a pillow for that
to hell. Helen's sleep has
the on. That's just a joke.
He likes sleep. Does not condone
any fucking violence towards wedge.
Heel asleep has thousands
of five star reviews,
plus you get a hundred
nights to try them out.
Tell them which hand you jerk off with.
They'll have a little elbow indentation
on that side of the mattress.
Go to Healy,
sleep.com/burr right now and you'll
get up to $125 towards your new fucking
mattress.
That's helix sleep.com/ [inaudible] for
up to 20 and $25 off your mad as hell.
Like sleep.com/burr h. E l. I x sleep
actors w when they'll,
while I'm playing a new guy so the guy
can't walk like me and they'll come up
with like a walk. Yeah, I don't know
those drones that are bring him up again.
And he told me,
he was talking about John Travolta one
time you saw him and John Travolta was
like, well, Vinny Barbarino
walked like this, Vincent
Vega walk like this, and boom.
It's just like, dude, he does the walks.
And I was thinking of the
little acting that I've done.
It's like every character I've done walks
like me, they would have to rewrite it.
He's, he's a serial killer
from Boston and he's a, yeah,
he's a Hawaiian guy from Boston.
Yeah. [inaudible] from Boston.
I didn't want him, they couldn't
justify why I wasn't from the Midwest.
So they said you went to college in
Boston and he picked up the accent,
but still,
for some reason he came back here and you
didn't go back to the accident that he
used to. He was raised by some assholes
from Boston, but in the middle,
which is a lot of reality TV, there's
always the loud Boston guy. So, um,
he likes watching interviews with
the Mark Wahlberg and uh, yeah,
but he doesn't have, he doesn't
have an accent. And Mark Wong. No,
I'm always amazed at how you
forget that he's, he can,
you can knock that out somehow. And I've
watched some, like I started out with uh,
Patrice O'Neal and Dane Cook and I saw
like an old Dane Cook stand up thing in
the last couple of years I saw it and in
like the mid nineties he had really big
time Boston extra. Now he doesn't.
Oh Wow. Like I don't know how,
I think you're really one of those
people like you just sort of like,
if he gets somewhere new you just sort of,
it just floats away or it's just stuck
in you. I think I'm, I'm sort of a,
I mean I don't have like a, you
work on it. Oh yeah. People work.
That's what Erin rid it. People do work
on it to get rid of it. And it's weird.
We have bill Hader here from air
inc I am going to pronunciate. Hi,
I'm from Boston, Massachusetts
now. I think that, yeah,
it that weird, vague way,
but I don't know. Yeah. It's like, I saw
this cooking show recently and this guy,
he was doing something, you know this
fucking guys travel and he goes, Boston,
you come here for a beer and a beating.
And I just moved.
I was looking at my life. I go,
Oh, you go to look at the foliage.
It's just like,
how many times did you watch good will
hunting before you went there to steam
your asparagus that you felt you had
to go that hard? You know, it's like,
there's also MIT, there's Harvard hate,
tasty, putting our hasty pudding.
There's a lot of like, you know,
you could go get some oysters.
Oysters be here in a beating,
because I live there for 27 years.
I never took a PT.
I walked away from fights and I was fine
with it. Yeah, you're tougher than me.
Your Dad was angrier than my dad.
You when I'm out of here.
Steamier his spirit. Yeah, with you.
Little poached egg on top of it.
I fucking hate the food network now.
They used to just have people they're
cooking and then teach you how to cook.
And then it became, you had to
have a personality and you know, I,
and I respect his cooking,
but I blamed that fucking Emeril Lagasse.
He's the guy I'm going to
fucking put some damn right.
And he had a studio audience in a band.
I used to be the assist
as an editor on a lot of those shows on
like iron chef America. I was, uh, uh,
I don't get that fucking show
is supposed to be real relaxing,
loving thing that you do and they take,
it's like death. You got to make waffles.
We got stones and,
and carpet.
How the fuck am I going to do
this? The fuck am I going, Mario,
let's see what you got.
And they're like, oh,
we used to have a thing of a Bobby flay,
a leg electric
Putin himself. He accidentally
electrocuted himself. It
was really fun. We did.
Yeah,
they cut it from the thing,
but he grabbed the ladle and something
happened and he just went and just
dropped out of frame. Oh Shit. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. We had to just have a thing of him.
It is his heart stopped.
I don't know.
But he dropped and then kind of
came up in a daze and we were uh,
he always seemed like he had into gestion
to me cause he would always be like,
okay, today we're going to
make, it's just like dude,
go off camera and Burp. Cause I, I
liked him. I like all of those guys.
They all taught me what little I know.
But like I,
I w I used to watch molto
Mario [inaudible] all the time,
which to me was a perfect one.
It's like you went over his
house and he cooked for you. Yes.
Like being his friend.
Yeah.
And then all of a sudden it just became
like that fucking guy yelling on iron
chef. Yeah. Or the diners
drive ins and dives guy,
which is hilarious because like he just
looks so burnt out on that show. Yeah.
What's his name? A guy. A guy fear.
He just says what you're doing.
Like you could make like a peanut
butter and jelly sandwich. So you are,
you're putting some peanut
butter on the bread and, okay.
And you get some jam in there.
That's gonna uh,
take a little edge off the peanut
butter and he makes so much money.
So much money. Oh my God.
It's to get the hard top.
Cause he's going to die a skincare,
but I looks like a fucking lobster.
This is coming from a redhead. I'm telling
you. He's got to get some sunblock. Um,
so what can we talk about about the
everybody, because this is a podcast.
It's not like people are dipping in here.
Yeah.
People know that the show
is on so they can, uh,
HBO is their Hbo streaming.net Org.
Yeah.
When you go to like, uh, well no, I
mean Amazon or Hulu or uh, uh, uh,
HBO go is the thing that's
gonna go. Yeah, it's great.
What would be best for you? Where should
they watch it? I, wherever they want.
I don't. Okay. I wasn't sure.
Louie had his show on Fx.
It would be like, you know,
can you please watch it?
So I get credit for people like watching
the advertising because everybody would
then it would record it and then fast
forward. I don't know. I know, yeah, they,
I mean to me it's just, yeah, just
watched. He'll be watch this show.
Hbo Has Been Amazing to work with the
fact that we could go in and pitch this
show to them and we're pitching a
half hour comedy and the two movies I
mentioned, or taxi driver and
unforgiven, you know, how did they,
how did they react to it? Like you coming
in and think, okay, it's bill Hader.
This is going to be funny. And
they thought it was going, yeah,
he come in with this and they go.
And to their credit they
were really excited about it.
It actually made them more excited.
See how many places you did you pitch
this show or there's just HBO because I
had to deal with them. And so I had this
kind of development deal with them and,
and I was shooting train wreck actually
in the whole time I was on a train wreck
going, what? You know, what am I going
to to, I have this deal now with Hbo,
but I got to write a show.
And so I met with Alec Berg
and then we came up with this.
And then I remember pitching it to them
and thinking, oh, they don't like it.
They don't like it,
but this is what I would rather want to
do it if I could do anything and be this.
And um, they, the, the, the fact
that they were the ones going, oh,
you know, I said, you know, the violence
has to be very real. It's not fun.
Have violent. The violence is not
funny at all. When he fights people,
I like it to feel real. I just don't,
I don't want it to be cool, you know?
And uh, they are absurd. Yeah.
Like weekend at Bernie's jokes,
you know what I mean? Like,
which you could easily do in this, you
know, there's a lot of times where you,
you know, there's a scene in
episode three where I, you know,
have to strangle a guy and
there's, there's in his
backyard, there's all these,
a child's, you know, kid toys and stuff.
And I remember Alec Berg and I were
shooting that scene and I said, you know,
any other place they would be
like, hey, can we make it funny?
Can you kill them with the
kids jump rope or, you know,
can we get some jokes in there or, you
know what I mean? And it's like, no,
it's not like the merger is
going to be too depressing. Yeah.
Because it's like you should be,
no, no, no, but he should kill him.
He should still kill them. But just funny,
you know, and you're like, no, but, uh,
we can't do that. I said this
before in the podcast, you know,
that's why I could never really watch,
I watched extra cause I
liked the performances,
but I couldn't fully commit to it cause
I could just hear the industry note.
Whereas like they went,
he's a serial killer and it's just like,
well how can we root for that?
And it's just like, all right,
he just kills the bad people. He's killer
with a good heart. And then I just was,
I just never was able,
well that's the hard thing.
That's been the nice thing with
Barry, at least as HBO, you know,
when we would turn in the drafts, you
know, and we get to later in the season,
especially,
it starts to get a very definitely
is not just killing the good people,
you know, bad people he's killing.
I gotta know I gotta go home.
I got to see it gets
terrible. And where he, he,
he ends up going, is, is a
pretty rough, but it was,
that was always just being honest to
that guy. You know what I mean? And that,
that's the thing that HBO has been
great about is that we'll say, hey,
is this too much? And they go, well,
what else are you going to do? You know,
they see it from a character standpoint.
They're like, well, what's his choice?
I saw at the two episodes and I, I, uh,
actually felt for the guy as far as like
how he became, that's another thing,
like he just, he's just not
like, oh, okay. He, Joseph's
born of psycho. It's like, oh,
this guy went to Afghanistan.
I can say this about Afghanistan,
did what he did over there and then got
into this line of work where you say
hitman. And he basically wants
to get out of it. And uh, and,
and just Henry Winkler's characters
with like the acting class.
And I took a bunch of acting classes.
I had a lot of,
I had some great acting
teachers and I had,
but the, but those words sums, you know,
when they became like the guru and,
um,
I met,
I can't remember this woman's
name and I only audited her class.
I audited to clay. I mean,
one on one class I audited,
it turned out it was Scientology.
Oh really? Oh, it was
hilarious. I went in there,
this actor who was in Scientology, he
goes, oh, you need an acting class.
And she sent me there and it was acting
class, but it was also like Scientology,
which I felt like she should have said,
right. That should have been, it's acting,
but there's a little extra thing. So
I go there, I go there and I remember,
uh,
we were sitting there and the,
and the guy teaching the class goes
a, does anybody have, uh, any, uh,
news they want to walk,
you know,
share with the class and someone
raised their hand and be like,
Oh, I, uh, you know, I,
I just book a three episode arc on a,
you know,
who gives a fuck on ABC? And then
the whole crew, the whole audience,
like ridiculously
lab or go
like this positive and I can put it,
it was crazy high. And I, I was sitting
there like, what the fuck? Right.
It's like five people did that and
then they go, hey, we have, we have,
we have two people auditing
the class. Uh, this guy is,
he's just fresh here from New
York. He's, he's an actor,
he's trying to get some parts, blah, blah,
blah, blah. Please welcome bill burr.
And they clapped.
Like I won a lifetime achievement award.
I remember my face turned red.
I was embarrassed.
So you know, and then I saw the scenes
in the actors would go and everything.
And then during the break,
like I remember the teacher was looking
at me and goes, what's a, was that,
was that too much? Did I push? Was that,
was I pushing? I'm sorry. Yeah.
So then I went in and I sat down
with them and they were just,
and he just kept saying everything was
their own. We have our own parking,
we have our own security, we have our
own this. And I swear to God, I said,
Jesus Christ,
I feel like I'm joining a cult.
Like I was trying to make a joke and he
kind of looked at me and his eyes were
like going from my right item. I
left that red. I was just saying,
what the fuck is going on?
So I got out of there and then I went
down to this call. I swear to God,
this is true. Went down to the
comedy club and I mentioned,
I say I took this acting class because
the actors were really good, but it was,
there was this just as fucking weird vibe.
And then I told him like the name of
the acting class, this guy goes, dude,
that's fucking Scientology.
And uh, I dunno,
I kind of felt like, you know, the next
time I saw that person I had that vibe.
Like, like they put something in
my drink like you should said,
I don't listen guys. Here's the
thing. Like I don't judge that.
Like I hate when people act like,
oh my God,
those people are out
of their fucking minds.
It's like my religion is
out of their fucking minds.
It's just they got enough people where
they can add cool now and they don't care
if you leave. Like Scientology needs
people. Yeah. So they got it, you know,
they got to lock in a room or
whatever it is. You need to say,
this is where you're going. You
need to say like, by the way,
you're going to a church.
I liked how they had their own network.
Now to come back cause that one woman
did like the Sh Alina Yemeni or whatever.
She did all this episode's
about how like crazy that was.
But I always feel like there's another
actor that could do the one about the
Catholic church. He bought them
anything. Yeah. Bang and kids.
And they made it seem like it was okay.
And that was the thing.
And you bought into it.
Um,
we're getting off track here.
Oh man, that's great. Well,
what I'm trying to do is I just don't
want to fucking sit here and ask you about
SNL and all of that shit
that I know. You've answered
a Zillion, a zillion times.
No, I'm, I'm loving this. I have no,
that's every a thing I go to is like
this is the word Stefan from or whatever,
you know. So how did you come up with
that and how did you come up with, so, um,
I will tell you my favorite thing I ever
saw you do was laughing uncontrollably.
Well, uh, uh, it was a lock.
The locker room thing. Oh,
foretastes 14. Yeah. Oh my God.
First he told me about that.
You literally have the towel.
I have a towel wrapped around
my face cause you know why?
Cause Forte did this dance and he did
it at the table read on Wednesday.
And I just said I can't,
there's no way I'm going to be
able to make it through that.
That's too funny cause he's a coach
trying to get us all riled up to go back
into the second half of the
game and to get us riled up.
He does this herb Albert,
this dances, her balance
Birdsong
and he does his dance. And
then, and uh, and then so yeah,
then I go, so before we went
on air, I go, Hey, will,
can you just do it for me a couple
of times just in my dressing room.
Can you just do it so I can like
laugh and get it out? That's great.
So can I just get it out?
So he did it,
but then on air he added a move.
Of course he just to fuck with me.
He added this thing. He went like
that. Like he couldn't hear me and uh,
and I lost it.
I just completely lost it.
And I started going and then I
remember said Degas was next to me.
You wanna know because I started going
and then Keenan Thompson started going,
cause we just hate pretty much Manny
lost it. Peyton a straight face. Oh no,
he, he kinda, he starts to put a towel
around his face. He gets, cause I just,
but I completely lost it.
Cause for it also was just,
it was such a forte thing, forte
just, he's not like I'm on,
you know, he's the one of those guys
very, hey man, I just very cool chill guy.
And then he would do these ideas or
something would happen to him and you go,
where's that, that he's, you know,
he would make me laugh that whole period,
all of those like you are you and you're
one of those guys like that was like,
that was like murderers row.
He, he, he had, he pitched,
he goes on a bill,
I'm going out with a movie and I go,
it's the movie you're doing.
He was I to do a movie
about a two brothers who,
who's switch bodies. And I go,
yeah. He goes, here's the thing,
they're identical.
It doesn't matter. And I go,
okay.
I go, how do people know
that they switched bodies?
All that's the joke is everyone acts
like, whoa, you're acting differently.
That's not like you, but they're just
acting. There are these two boring guy.
So tell me he was doing to sustain
that for heat for 90 minute that out.
And I was like, he told me that
and I laugh for, I just want it,
where the hell did you come with that?
And you know,
I'm going to write this movie
about these two guys. So yeah,
he's just a genius and a
great guy too. But yeah, no,
I felt very lucky when I was there with
all those people, Kristen and, and uh,
Andy and Fred Armisen and all those
guys. I mean, it was crazy. Yeah.
And you guys have all gone on to do
stuff. So right now are you, uh, are you,
when do you start back
up with the next season?
Or do you get the writing it right now?
We're writing season two right now.
Oh God.
Did you get any of the,
how much of a break did you get
to cheat a bit of a break? Yeah.
I mean we finished all this in August,
so Barry was done in August. Oh, okay.
Then it starts airing and then,
you know,
we opened up a writer's room
and you know, HBO uh, told us,
you know,
yeah,
you guys can we do more is it's going
to be another eight as of right now,
who knows? We might change that,
but as of right now it's eight.
I kinda liked that people,
I like being able to craft eight episodes
and kind of make it a very, you know,
kind of a tight season, you know,
and with a good story to it.
Back in the day when there was a great
album is a lot of times it was eight
songs. Yeah. But then when the 10
song came out, it's like, all right,
here's the fucking valid. I'm just
trying to fill it. I get it. I get it.
It's the same thing with TV
in a way where you go, oh,
when are we going to watch an
episode that's all about, you know,
the gardener or something and you go,
I don't care about this. You know,
I want to know. I don't want
to, I want to know what else is.
I know JD that I don't consider that
groundbreaking. I'm just like, yeah,
you guys wanted an episode.
I think the series regulars are bitching
about their contracts. That guy,
but we got to keep the train moving.
Let's, so let's do something about it.
That guy, that guy, guess what? You're
starring in the show, the sweat asshole.
You're carrying the shelf
and if it goes down,
you never play a gardener in
this town again. You piece
of shit. Um, well anyways,
thank you so much for,
uh, for coming on. Oh Man.
Oh my head hurts. I'm laughing so much.
That was great. That's all my interviews.
Want to be good. I don't want
anybody to learn anything about you.
I just want to give you a break
from the same fucking 20 questions,
but I'm so happy for you,
man. Thank you buddy.
That means a lot to be already done. So
much brilliant work. And the fact that,
you know, HBO shout out to them
for being so cool to let a,
a comedic actor, I don't know
how to define what, what,
what, what it is sketchy.
I don't know how, I just know
comedian. What, what, what,
what do you, I don't know.
I don't know,
like sketch,
act or to SNL and they let
you do something like that
as a pen to write it and
direct. I never directed before and
they let me direct stuff and I mean, uh,
you know, I directed the first three
episodes and to write and all that and so,
yeah,
just to be able to have so much faith
and crazy Eddie Murphy 48 hours.
Stephanie's, yeah, the acting that
he does in that he so God damn funny,
but when it has to be real, he's
incredible. And then what was the,
what was the one who got nominated for
the, uh, flipping name? Girl dream girls?
Yeah. I, for the life of me,
I don't understand why he
doesn't get more stuff on d.
I will say it,
not of it,
but that 48 hours scene when he goes
into the redneck bar and you know,
the cowboy is one of the few scenes
in movie history where you're like,
that's a movie stars just been born.
Yeah. We're what, with one scene,
it's very rare where you can go, you
know, like John Wayne and stage coach,
they always say they push in on
in his first shot and stage coach.
And everybody went, wow,
who does that guy? You know?
But Eddie Murphy in that scene, I just
remember, I remember I didn't see, but my,
my dad's seen that movie
and coming back and going,
there's this guy in the movies,
the new guy on SNL.
It is like one of the funniest
things. He's phenomenal. You gotta
See, you know? Yeah. And what else? I, I,
that is the best gun sounds.
Oh yeah.
Walter Hill's movies always have
like this cannon. Unbelievable.
Unbelievable. And, you know
something. I actually, uh,
got to do an acting gig
where I, I played, uh, um,
oh fuck. I'm so bad with the named Jason.
Uh, he played Mike on breaking bed. Oh,
I know who talking about Jason. Yeah,
he's great. And I got, I got to talk,
I got to talk to him about
being on 48 hours. Wow.
Uh, he's like, God dammit.
Jacked up joke Joe don't,
Tony goes to kiss him the gun and then
he also got thrown over the buffet table,
um,
in a,
in Beverly hills cop and he hasn't been
one of my favorite lines in airplane. Oh,
he was an airplane? Yeah. He goes,
the guy just went from 500,000 feet
to 20,000 feet. What an answer.
He's the guy on the radio
or watching like, yeah. This
guy to see that again. Yeah.
He just, they cut away to
him. He was like, oh, I just
went from, it's like, yeah,
25,000 feet to 7,000 feet. What
an ass. I remember that line.
I just don't remember. That was, that was
him. Yeah. He's also the guy that I go,
how are we doing any opens up a, it's a
like a Turkey. And there he was like, oh,
we're almost done. We're almost finished
here, sir. And it's like, so just dumb.
But he's great. I mean, that's one of
the best, the best movies. But yeah, no,
the gunfight, the gun sounds in 48
hours. All those Walter Hill movies,
he always had like a really cool sound
design in his movies. He's great. Yeah.
Although the whole thing I
actually want to, I about,
well this is like the epilogue
of the plot. Just this point.
I was on the subway and the actor
that played Luther w, you know,
the guy from warriors, he was sitting like
right across from me. He had, you know,
he looked great. I mean, it's like
I'm be 20 years ago I saw him. Wow.
What am I just the way he
delivered that line, uh, when he,
uh, when Nick Nolte is beating him up
with the door and he goes, you know,
system like, well, I think you're
lying. And the line is, yeah. Well,
who gives a fuck what you think?
And he doesn't yell to the Word Fuck.
He just goes, yeah, well, who
gives a fuck what you think?
Why would you yell at Fuck?
Who gives a fuck what you think of?
Who gives a fuck what you did?
The way he did that he has?
That was like the catchphrase
in my family. Yeah. Who
gives a fuck what you, yeah.
He has such weird rhythms. That guy
all the warriors to, I mean like,
he's such as Drake.
He has such a cool way of speaking.
You just are like, yeah, well you
can learn a lot from that guy.
People are going to learn a lot
from you watching this. Uh, this,
this Sunday's episode or go on Hbo.
Go to check it out.
Barry starring Bill Hader. Thank you. Ah,
thank you so much for coming on
the podcast. Thank you buddy.